hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be all about Jaime Lannister's
history there's just like a couple
really big signposts in his character's
history and most of them are really well
documented some by other characters some
by himself
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far here we go the earliest period
that we know about is him at Casterly
Rock growing up with Cersei most of his
history there is narrated by Cersei but
some also by Jaime himself specifically
talking about the birth of Tyrion
although Cersei talks a little bit about
the birth of Tyrion - and looked like a
much more sinister way she's found a way
to blame him for just about every
problem that she's had if you remember
Cersei in the flashback in the first
episode of season 5 most of the early
history that we know about happens
before that so when they're much much
younger the way Cersei tells that she
and Jamie were fairly typical children I
mean typical noble born children they
exhibited some of the personality traits
that their adult characters on the show
have right now but you can write off a
lot of Circe's cruelty you know before
this incident with Maggy the Frog as
children or cruel everybody's been to
grade school children can be mean like
that's just the way children are until
they develop morals and a conscience and
just like that consistency Jaime was
kind of the same whereas Cersei was very
cruel to Tyrion in his crib Jaime tried
to stay her hand he tried to protect him
but probably like the most fun thing
about Jaime as a child or the most funny
thing depending on how you look at it is
that when when they were I would say
like younger than ten Cersei would dress
up as Jamie and Jamie would dress up as
Cersei because they they look so alike
and they would walk around the castle to
see if anybody would notice and usually
no one would notice they didn't start
getting into trouble together until they
started making out yes they did that at
a very very young age before that
they've been they've been allowed to
spend as much time together as they
wanted day or night but after that like
their handlers like all the people that
were in charge of taking care of them
around the castle started to separate
them more and more they like they saw
what was going on and they're like okay
we need to stop this right now
because he became a squire at the age of
11 so he was sent to another castle the
place he was sent to was Crakehall
but that that was the beginning of his
training within a couple years he
participated in his first tournament and
it started to get better and better and
better so you start to see the Jaime
Lannister that you meet
the first episode of season 1 but the
next like really big signposts in
Jamie's history was his encounter with a
smiling Knight that actually that
happened when he was still squiring for
Lord Crakehall
he was before he joined the Kingsguard
he was only about 15 years old it was
called the campaign against the
Kingswood Brotherhood so there's like
really big badass group of bandits led
by a person called the smiling Knight
who kind of looked like the mountain he
was Tino he's huge they kidnapped a
bunch of nobles for ransom and they were
hiding out in the Kingswood it became
such a problem that the Mad King sent a
force to try and deal with them
Lord Craig was just ordered to be a part
of that so naturally Jaime being the
squire had to go along Jaime remembers
it is one of his fondest memories just
because it was before he joined the
Kingsguard before his life got really
complicated he crossed swords with the
smiling Knight but it was Arthur Dayne
that ended up killing him remember this
is like going up against the mountain
Jaime refers to him as the mountain of
his day Jaime would have died had it not
been for Arthur Dayne who ended up
training him once he did join the
Kingsguard so this is like this before
Jaime was like amazing with a sword so
Jamie starts heading home to Casterly
Rock after the campaign but he stops off
at King's Landing to see Cersei who had
been living there for a while and it's
Wally's there that Cersei
tells Jaime about Tywin's plants to
marry him off to Lysa Tully
Cersei not wanting to lose him suggests
to Jaime that he become part of the
Kingsguard so that she could be close to
him now remember this is before Robert's
rebellion
so Cersei isn't at King's Landing to
marry Robert she was at King's Landing
because Tywin still had hopes for
marrying her to a Targaryen namely
Daenerys his older brother remember
Rhaegar Targaryen had already been
betrothed to Elia Martell but there was
still one more male Targaryen heir he's
about 10 years younger than Cersei but I
mean just look at Margaery and Tommen
look at the age gap there so despite
marriage plans for Cersei like she's
still pretty convinced that she's gonna
be marrying a Targaryen she wants Jaime
near her so she's like why don't you
throw yourself under the bus join the
Kingsguard and you can be near me all
the time so Cersei arranged
behind-the-scenes at King's Landing to
try and get Jaime on the King's garden I
mean she didn't just go straight to King
Aerys and be like could you name Jaime
to the Kingsguard like she didn't go
right
and ask him but what she did not know is
that tension had been building between
the Mad King in Tywin Lannister so the
king was more than happy to name Jaime
to the Kingsguard because it means that
Tywin will lose his heir so within the
span of like a month they have the
tourney at Harrenhal like the famous
tourney at Harrenhal where Rhaegar
Targaryen gave lyanna stark's the crown
of blue roses during that King Aerys
named Jaime to the Kingsguard in front
of half the kingdom remember this is
like a really big tournament because the
rumor is is that Rhaegar was going to
marshal the lords to call a great
council and depose his father now that's
just like a fan theory but Rhaegar had
backed the winnings for the tournament
so that there was so much money on the
line that everybody wanted a piece of it
so almost like the entire kingdom came
to this one tournament so everybody got
to watch the Mad King give Tywin
Lannister a giant black eye you know
without actually giving him a black eye
so Jaime and Cersei think that their
plan has worked
Jaime's joining the Kingsguard they'll
both be in King's Landing they can be
together but Tywin you know not really
realizing what they've been trying to do
throws a giant wrench in the plan
because he's pissed at King Aerys he
resigns his hand of the King returns to
Casterly Rock and brings Cersei back
with him so Jaime is stuck in King's
Landing now and Cersei is stuck at
Casterly Rock the next big event in
Jamie's life is actually pretty
well-documented it's when he earned his
name the Kingslayer so Jaime has to
watch as the Mad King burns Brandon and
Rickard stark that's Ned Stark's brother
and his father and says he just kind of
went away inside himself sir jailed
Hightower's like standing there next to
him as this is happening saying you
swore a vow to guard the King not to
judge him so Robert's rebellion starts
because the North remembers when you
kill one of their Lords and because
Rhaegar Targaryen had stolen Lyanna
stark or or absconded with her Jaime
tried to join the army and he tried to
go off and like in fight in the battles
that he might have done a pretty good
job but the Mad King forced him to stay
at King's Landing to protect him he
wanted to keep Tywin Lannister loyal to
the throne by keeping his oldest son
right next to him as if he would
threaten Jaime's life so that's probably
one of the only reasons that Tywin did
not fight with Robert you have to
remember the the reason the King Aerys
was so afraid of Tywin I mean he if he's
insane but on top of that Tywin was
most powerful person in the kingdom this
is long before the Lannister gold mines
has started to run dry
so as the rebellion is nearing its
conclusion it becomes pretty clear that
the Mad King is going to lose so he
devises this plan that he's going to
destroy King's Landing using wildfire
rather than let it fall into Roberts
hands so at the very end just before the
sack of King's Landing Jaime is the only
Kingsguard left he is completely in
charge of defending the red keep Tywin
rouses his forces Fianna fearing for
Jaime's safety and comes to defend
King's Landing but once Tywin gets
inside he betrays the Mad King
so it's Tywin that began the actual sack
of King's Landing
Jaime realizing what's going on asked
the Mad King hate you no please let me
go out there and we'll treat with them
the mad Kings response to that is that
he wants Jaime to bring him Tywin's head
to prove that he is no traitor bring him
his father's head just completely
batshit crazy the Mad King before he ran
the Mad King through he actually crapped
his pants
the met the Mad King soiled himself
Jaime said that he squealed like a pig
as he died and to keep him from giving
the final order for the pyromancers to
set fire to the city with wildfire he
slit his throat the rest of the story we
know they've actually narrated it quite
a bit on the show Ned Stark walks in and
sees Jaime's standing over the body of
the Mad King he gets labelled the
Kingslayer and it becomes this big slide
on his honor for the rest of his life
that was the most defining moment in his
life till he lost his hand now he's just
a one-handed Kingslayer trying to find a
way to reclaim some of his own honor at
least in his own eyes if not in the eyes
of everyone else if you remember when he
and Brienne were in the bathtub and he
was telling her the story of how he got
the name the Kingslayer and she was like
why didn't you tell anyone what happened
like why didn't you tell him that stark
he's like he would have never believed
me
so you lured Amy's history is a lot more
complicated than it's made out to be so
you understand why he dissociates with
reality so much it's just like you know
he feels so powerless but he is not
completely without common sense so I'm
really interested to see how he reacts
to what's going on with Cersei back in
King's Landing like will Cersei start
looking like the Mad King will she go on
a tear and if she does what
jaimé going to do because remember you
can't choose who you love but he's not
gonna let her metaphorically burn down
the city I mean she's not gonna do the
exact same thing the Mad King did but
she might end up doing something that's
just as destructive that's actually
really good jumping-off point here's my
big question for you guys like what do
you think is Jamie's limit with Cersei
like at one point will he completely cut
ties I know it's a little bit different
in the books but the shows have also
kind of painted it that way too he still
cares about her but they're not together
like they were in the past just pasting
on the pacing of each season I could
totally see Cersei like you know try to
claw her way back to power across season
six and then if Jamie and her have some
sort of like final break it probably
won't happen till season seven sometimes
there are storylines that feel like they
go really fast and some feel like they
go really slow so just a quick reminder
because I forgot to mention it earlier
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I will do a Q&A tomorrow so leave
all your questions I'll announce the
giveaway winner net - I haven't done too
many Robert's rebellion videos so my
next bonus video might be for like some
things going on during that period there
were some really interesting stuff that
happened between Jamie and Rhaegar
Targaryen but he died the Trident so it
all it all went to but I just think
you know based on some of the stuff that
went down between them it gives you a
really good idea of what Rhaegar might
have done differently had he not died so
while you guys wait for me to post that
Q&A case you didn't see it this morning
I posted like a really big update on a
bunch of big platform changes that
YouTube is going through and some stuff
behind the scenes that's going on with
my channel some really good stuff it's
all really good news so you can click
here to check that out learn what's
going on and you can click here to learn
all about Arthur Dayne a character
that's very important to Jaime's
backstory so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow